hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and in this video
i will be breaking down all of aaron's
many titan forms and powers throughout
the entire attack on titan story from
beginning to end these forms and powers
are not just cool to talk about they
also drive the plot of the entire series
to a large extent so understanding them
helps us understand the story as a whole
that is why i will be breaking it all
down right here in one video for your
convenience if you enjoy our attack on
titan content and you want us to keep it
going just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
really helps with the youtube algorithm
and of course if you're new to the
channel or you watch our videos but you
just haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a quick favor and make this
the video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you're looking for more
attack on titan content we have an
entire playlist with different attack on
time videos so check that out i will
link it down in the description finally
this video will of course contain attack
on titan manga spoilers i am dealing
with all the information from the manga
and the anime so please proceed with
caution you have been warned let's start
it off with aaron's pure titan form the
titan he was turned into initially
before he ate grisha and became a titan
shifter aaron's pure titan was very
different from his attack titan shifter
form although it did have some features
that resembled a young aaron this titan
was only 4 meters tall it had a large
head and stocky body and we only got to
see it very briefly in a flashback so
there isn't too much that we can say
about it aaron had no memory of turning
into a pure titan and devouring his
father and so once he eventually
transformed into the attack titan he was
as surprised as everyone else
speaking of the attack titan let's talk
about aaron's initial titan shifter form
aaron first unlocks the ability to
transform into the attack titan during
the battle of trost when he is swallowed
and nearly killed by a pure titan the
anguish and desperation that aaron feels
in this moment as he witnesses his
comrades dying and being devoured by
this same titan triggers aaron's first
transformation into the attack titan he
turns into a titan inside the titan who
consumed him and so aaron's
transformation tears the other titan
apart in case you're wondering why the
pure titan that consumed aaron didn't
become a titan shifter himself it is
because he still hadn't killed aaron and
consumed his spinal fluid aaron had not
been digested yet and so he was able to
transform before being completely
devoured as i said earlier aaron's
attack titan form is very different from
his pure titan this titan is 15 meters
tall so much bigger than his 4 meter
pure titan and rather than being stocky
his body is extremely athletic and
muscular initially aaron has no
conscious control while in his attack
titan form and he also has no clear
memory of what he did as a titan so his
titan functions on pure instinct and the
driving instinct for him is to kill
every titan at all costs so in pursuit
of this goal aaron's attack titan
overexerts himself and even injures his
own body in the process of killing other
titans on top of transforming into a
titan fully aaron is also able to
perform a partial titan transformation
for example he protects mikasayan armin
from a cannonball by creating an
incomplete torso titan and erecting it
as a protective barrier after multiple
transformations aaron becomes more
accustomed to being on titan shifter and
he progressively becomes more capable of
controlling his titan form it is clear
from the start that aaron's titan is
more physically powerful than the
average titan and this is shown multiple
times in the early stages of the story
aaron's titan is able to take down as
many as 20 mindless titans during his
first titan transformation and he even
manages to take one titan's head off
with a single punch later aaron is able
to lift a massive boulder on his own and
slam it down in order to plug the hole
in trost district this feat demonstrates
a far better strength to body size ratio
than the average titan we later learned
that the attack titan was always
physically strong even before aaron
gained that power in his own attack
titan form the owl aaron krueger was
able to raise an entire massive ship out
of the ocean and onto his shoulders
later in the story aaron proves that his
titan can do the exact same thing along
with exceptional physical strength
aaron's titan also has above average
endurance for example aaron is able to
turn into a titan three times over a
short period of time which is not
something that every titan shifter is
capable of now all titan shifters have
the ability to regenerate their bodies
which allows them to quickly heal from
even the most severe injuries although
we have to say that some titan shifters
are able to regenerate more quickly and
efficiently than others aaron's attack
titan is quite efficient when it comes
to regeneration and he is able to
regenerate major wounds including lost
limbs quite quickly aaron can of course
use this impressive regeneration power
in both his titan and his human form as
he gets accustomed to being a titan
shifter aaron begins seeing fragments of
his father grisha's memories and it is
eventually revealed that the attack
titan has a very special power that no
other titan possesses that is of course
the ability to access future memories in
short the current attack titan holder
can see the memories of future attack
titan holders or he can send his own
memories into the past in order to share
them with previous attack titan holders
aaron was able to selectively share his
memories with his father grisha in the
past and ultimately these memories were
shared with his own past self in the
moment that aaron came into contact with
historia's hand this ability for future
aaron to share his memories with past
aaron plays a major role in the attack
on titan story and in fact this ability
completely changes aaron's character arc
and the ultimate outcome of the series
aaron also has the hardened attack titan
mode he is not able to harden his titan
at first but he unlocks this ability
after he drinks a serum labeled armor
which had belonged to the rhys royal
family after drinking the serum aaron is
able to harden his entire titan body and
he is also able to generate a series of
pillars from his body that can spread
all around the titan these pillars and
aaron's hardened titan body will not
disappear after aaron leaves his titan
they will remain hard indefinitely aaron
trains for several months with hanji in
order to master his titan hardening and
he is later able to use this hardening
ability to plug holes in the walls that
the warriors had created on top of
hardening his entire titan body aaron
can also choose to harden certain parts
of his body only such as his fists and
arms he is able to use this ability in
combat for both offensive and defensive
purposes his hardened punches are able
to break even the armored titans face
armor and his hardened arms are able to
block even the strongest attacks now
it's time to talk about the infamous
berserk mode which was an anime only
addition that didn't really have any
equivalent in the manga so back when
aaron's attack titan was fighting
annie's female titan in stohe's district
annie completely subdued aaron's attack
titan and he helplessly watched as she
got away from him and started climbing
the wall to escape unfortunately for her
mikasa then appeared and cut her titan's
fingers so annie's titan fell to the
ground and was captured at least this is
what happened in the manga in the anime
this scene went down very differently in
the anime as annie runs away from aaron
and towards the wall aaron does not just
watch helplessly inside his titan aaron
reiterates his vow to kill all titans
and then his body begins to change the
attack titan's eyes begin to glow blue
and lava-like veins also start glowing
across his body the attack titan goes
completely berserk it starts acting like
a wild beast and it chases down annie
before tackling her to the ground even
his movements are very different in this
mode as he catches up to annie aaron's
titan moves more like an ape than a
human eren's titan then nearly kills
annie but she manages to kick him away
and she begins climbing the wall in the
end mikasa arrives just like in the
manga and cuts her fingers forcing her
to drop back down to the ground this
so-called berserk mode might have just
been a reflection of aaron's rage in
that moment but that doesn't really
explain the clear physical changes on
his titan's body such as the glowing
eyes and veins for a very long time fans
have speculated that this anime-only
berserk mode could pop up again at some
point in the future although it never
was introduced into the manga so if it
does pop up in the final season of the
anime it will again be an anime only
phenomenon frankly i do wish that we got
to see more of this berserk form because
it is extremely cool the glowing eyes
and veins the animalistic ape-like
movements the completely wild and
uncontrollable behavior all of that is
definitely something that would have
been cool to see again let me know what
you guys thought about berserk mode
attack titan and will it ever be
referenced again in the anime oh and of
course if you made it this far into the
video leave a like and subscribe
seriously that really helps me out here
on youtube and it also encourages me to
keep grinding out more content for you
guys the next stage of aaron's titan
evolution that i want to briefly touch
upon is his absorption of the warhammer
titan power there doesn't really appear
to be any real difference in aaron's
titan's appearance as a result of him
consuming the warhammer titan although
of course he does gain the ability to
use the warhammer titan's powers this
includes producing giant spikes from the
ground and his own body tunneling
underground and so on that said after
the time skip aaron's titan form does
have longer hair which reflects the
changes in aaron's own human form there
are also some inevitable differences
that come with the change of anime
studios such as the titans eye color but
those are not necessarily related to the
form of the titan itself and now it's
time to talk about the big one literally
aaron's gigantic earth-shattering
founding titan transformation ever since
he first inherited the attack titan
power aaron also possessed the founding
titan power because grisha had stolen it
from frieda reese and then passed both
powers onto aaron at the same time
however because aaron doesn't have royal
blood the founding titan's power was
just lying dormant inside of him the
only exception was the brief moment in
which aaron came into contact with the
smiling titan the smiling titan was once
dina fritz grisha's first wife and
zeke's mother and she had royal blood it
is this royal blood that temporarily
activated a fragment of aaron's founding
titan power which allowed him to command
a bunch of pure titans in order to fully
harness the power of the founding titan
aaron uses his half-brother zeke who
also has royal blood in order to gain
access to emir fritz through the paths
once there aaron convinces emir to stop
obeying the fritz royal bloodline and to
trust him to free her and help her put
an end to this horrible world this
allows aaron to finally use the many
overpowered abilities of the founding
titan including communicating
telepathically with all subjects of emir
through the paths if he wanted to he
could also change the very biology of
every aldean for instance he could make
them all sterile or he could alter their
bodies in a way that allows them to
fight off diseases more easily and he
could even take away all of their titan
powers if he wanted to aaron then
initiates the rumbling and so the
millions of colossal titans within the
walls on paradise set out to destroy
everyone and everything except for the
island of paradise itself but the
millions of colossal titans marching in
unison to trample the entire world
beneath their feet is not even the
creepiest thing that happens in this
part of the story perhaps the single
creepiest thing in all of attack on
titan is aaron's founding titan form a
massive skeletal spider-esque
monstrosity that towers far above even
the colossal titans this is by far the
biggest titan that we've ever seen in
the history of attack on titan and even
other founders like emir fritz's own
titan can't measure up to it there is no
exact height measurement for aaron's
gigantic founding titan but my own
conservative estimates suggest that he
is at least 500 meters tall if not more
and let's just think about that for a
second because that is absolutely insane
just as a quick reminder the wall titans
are about 50 meters tall on top of its
unbelievable size and raw destructive
power aaron's founding titan also has
the ability to summon all former titan
shifters from history and control them
in order to fight off any potential
enemies there doesn't even appear to be
a limit to how many titan shifters can
be summoned at any one time so
essentially the founding titan shifter
can create an entire army of former
titan shifters that are completely
controlled by the founder aaron is also
able to detach his head from this
massive founding titan and then create a
new colossal titan form for himself this
colossal titan is the same size as
armin's titan and the only major
difference is that aaron's colossal
titan has very long hair while armin's
is bald in his own colossal titan form
aaron is able to overcome armin's titan
in hand-to-hand combat
and that is it all of eren's titan forms
and titan powers explained if you enjoy
our attack on titan videos and you want
us to keep them coming then just leave a
quick like and subscribe to the channel
this only takes a couple of seconds but
it helps us out a lot on youtube and of
course it's a completely free way to
directly support the channel also don't
forget to comment down below what your
favorite aaron titan forms and abilities
are i look forward to hearing from you
finally feel free to check me out on
twitter and instagram at animeopror as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys